[Música]
en Estados Unidos el estado de Tennessee
prohibió que se realicen shows drag
Queen en público o en lugares donde
puedan ser vistos por menores de edad es
la primera vez que se produce una ley
como estas en todo el país pero no es la
primera normativa Estatal que restringe
las expresiones y la autodeterminación
de la comunidad diversa los estados
dominados por republicanos se movilizan
con más ahínco desde la presidencia de
Donald Trump para aprobar medidas
conservadoras como la mal llamada ley no
digas gay en Florida para hablar del
tema nos acompaña vedet ella es artista
drac cantante compositora y cofundadora
de la productora más
visibles.a r le doy gracias por estar
con nosotros Mientras que el Gobernador
de tennes y el republicano Billy
sancionaba la ley como un triunfo grupos
de Derechos Humanos denuncian
discriminación por qué prohíben
expresiones drac en espacios públicos y
como atenta esto contra la comunidad
lgbtiq más bueno aporta un montón contra
la intolerancia y además como que
también buscan legitimizar legitimizar
este odio no que que no tiene mucho
sentido a mí me parece que es como
correr el eje y buscar algo de reacción
algo para tener a la gente enojada
ofuscada con esos pero no se va a ningún
lado más que es como una ley sin mucho
sentido sin mucho sostén porque también
atenta contra el trabajo no solo de las
drag Queens pensemos que tal vez Harry
Styles puede quedar dentro de esta
nuestra denominación cuando él se viste
y con ropa que se supone que no sería de
su género es una persecución hacia lo
femenino hacia la libertad y la verdad
que no tiene mucho sentido más allá de
Buscar Elevar el odio y más allá de
Elevar odio Usted qué opina de Por qué
se argumenta que esto podría atentar
contra los menores de edad
es una ridiculez es una ridiculez la
verdad que no tiene sentido porque todas
las personas que hacemos drag lo hacemos
de distintas formas y lo hacemos para en
realidad para entretenernos para
divertirnos es un es un arte lúdico lo
que buscan no sé por qué ponen esa
carátula de que es para proteger a los
niños porque en Estados Unidos vos vas
al supermercado y compras un arma y hay
más muertes por armas que por cáncer y
obviamente una drag Queen no es algo
peligroso no es una terrorista somos
artistas no tiene sentido de usan a los
niños para llevar adelante otros planes
pero no les interesan los niños eso está
claro Sin embargo a pesar de que esto no
afecta contra los menores de edad Como
usted lo dice ya hay otros estados en el
país que están promoviendo leyes
similares como Florida que en todo aquí
hay bajo o Dakota del Norte Se podrían
promover más normativas al respecto en
Estados Unidos y cuéntenos también Cómo
es el panorama al respecto en América
Latina
bueno por suerte América Latina esto no
estaría ocurriendo la Argentina es un
país muy de vanguardia en género pero de
todas formas esto hay que verlo con
preocupación porque no es que acá no
están los grupos de derecha
organizándose y trabajando con esta
intolerancia con la llamada bajada de
línea de género no la ideología de
género como nos demonizan
lo veo con mucha preocupación esto que
comentas de que Florida también está
pensando aplicar esta ley es una
persecución ridícula y me hace pensar
mucho en los edictos policiales acá
cuando terminó la dictadura continuaban
la policía pudiéndote detener porque
usabas ropa que no pertenecía a tu
género y sin pasar por un juez la
policía te detenía y podías estar un mes
en la cárcel es una ridiculez y es muy
peligroso porque de esto continuar
inicia una persecución a una comunidad
que estamos siempre en persecución en la
comunidad trans está muy desvalida
y esto lo hace legal es una persecución
terrible lo veo con mucha preocupación
por suerte América Latina es un páramo
en la diversidad y estamos dando batalla
bueno Y como usted bien lo explica esta
persecución se está englobando en la
llamada ideología de género que como
usted explica Es un término que se está
utilizando en Argentina también se ha
utilizado en Colombia para modificar
incluso normas cuéntenos Cuáles podrían
ser las consecuencias que esta clase de
leyes puede traer para la comunidad drag
y sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que
según la organización estadounidense de
Trevor project uno de cada cinco jóvenes
trans o no binarios se suicidan
sí absoluto continuamos con la
persecución no porque esto va en contra
de explorar Quiénes somos el drac más
allá de una forma artística es una forma
de explorar la identidad jugando con lo
que nos permiten lo que nos dicen que es
ser una mujer o ser un hombre
no no lo veo para nada bien con respecto
a lo que va a ser el la proyección
laboral
se meten con lo que nosotros hacemos lo
demonizan como si fuésemos un No sé digo
por qué no van en contra del internet
digo si tanto les preocupa esto que nos
ponen como en un rol sexual o perverso
un niño entra a la computadora con
internet y accede a lo que quiera
Entonces dónde es que una drag Queen se
vuelve tan peligrosa y además va en
contra de las fuentes de trabajo y la
expresión es un derecho no poder hablar
libremente expresarnos en las formas que
queremos
[Música]
él va en contra del trabajo y va a
escalar con esto que te menciono de por
ejemplo no sé bion se hace un recital Y
qué pasa con ella Madonna por ejemplo no
como que es Volver al pasado un pasado
peligroso
Gracias por estas alertas que usted nos
está dando aquí en France 24 Muchas
gracias hasta luego y sigan ustedes
conectados aquí porque en minutos
traemos todas las noticias
internacionales
[Música]